today's highly anticipated testimony in
Washington could help define the Trump
presidency but this will not be the
first time congressional hearings have
gripped the nation chip Reid is at the
heart Senate office building on Capitol
Hill to show us others that have had a
lasting impact chip good morning well
good morning to put this in context this
is one of just a handful of hearings
over the years that have risen to the
level of being broadcast live on network
TV so while we're waiting for James
Comey to arrive here to begin his
testimony let's take a look back at some
of the other blockbuster hearings that
have riveted the nation and shaped
history until this moment senator I
think I never really gauge your cruelty
or your recklessness in a 1954 hearing
army lawyer Joseph Welch expressed
frustration with Senator Joseph McCarthy
and his ruthless anti-communist crusade
have you know fans of decent leader
presidential historian Robert Dalek
remembers when then Senate Majority
Leader lyndon b johnson arranged for a
television network to broadcast the
congressional testimony and johnson knew
this that once they saw mccarthy with
his five o'clock shadow and having
people see how rude and abusive he could
be it undercut him terribly our
activities in south vietnam years later
in 1966 the vietnam hearings exposed a
stunning admission
I think our military involvement in
Vietnam has to be recognized as
unfortunate as something we would not
choose deliberately if the choice were
ours to make all over again today the
u.s. was stuck in a war it was unlikely
to win it raised questions about what
was the purpose of it why were we
fighting there from the iran-contra
affair I came here to tell you the truth
to the infamous she said I could not
keep silent he said it is a high-tech
lynching of the Clarence Thomas Anita
Hill scandal public hearings have become
part politics part theater Americans
watched as Bill Clinton became the
second president in US history to
undergo an impeachment trial
it depends upon what the meaning of the
word is yeah that's exactly what we did
and then watched again when Hillary
Clinton endured an 11 hour grilling from
the house Benghazi committee I have been
racking my brain about what more could
have been done or should have been done
the most explosive hearing of all was
Watergate these mistakes were made by
only a few participants in the campaign
it uncovered the extent of the cover-up
by the Nixon administration
I began by telling the president there
was a cancer growing on the presidency
what began with a burglary ended with
President Nixon's resignation and so of
course it leads up to these coma
hearings which create a sense of
anticipation that people may hear
something that's going to change the
course of history it's the kind of new
national soap opera
it is perhaps ironic that today's
hearing is expected to preempt some soap
operas and as soon as the searing ends
today you can bet that the pundits and
historians will begin debating exactly
where this ranks in the history of
congressional witnesses charlie chip
thanks we'll be watching